GameSpot's here at pax los 2020 and
we've played so many games but we're
here to tell you about our favorites
from the show without a doubt my
favorite game of PAX East was Street to
rage for I'm a huge fan of the original
series er rage series I think it's one
of the most satisfying and just sort of
stylized like beat em ups ever made and
you know I was so glad to see a return
this game in particular is coming from
lizzard cubed they recently did the
Wonder Boy remaster about that came out
a few years ago so they're very much
continuing on with that very stylized
and so very hyper detailed like you know
2d art this game is just an incredibly
stylized you sort of take on sort of the
beat them up like you know the genre
except it's a bit more modern now
because we have like not only expanded
local co-op of up to four players but
also online co-op as well and me and
Michael actually got to play with the
devs so we were just as a game just
going through the streets like you know
beating people up and and we actually
like all four of us ganged up on this
one guy and like you know we almost got
up to 100 hits and uh please show that
clip if we can by the way I'm just very
excited just to be able to go back to
Streets of Rage again you know I'm just
a huge fan of the series and this game
just really you know sort of like ticked
all the right boxes for me so yeah I
want to see more of that game
so my favorite game from PAX East was a
little something called Alien Hominid
invasion like 15 years later they're
finally making a sequel to Alien Hominid
and I don't know maybe sequel is not the
right word the devs don't like using the
word sequel because they call like a
reimagining you're still an alien you're
still running and gunning and shooting
secret agents and like fighting these
big bosses you can still do that
cooperatively but where the first game
sort of locked you on a one screen and
it was a level by level progression this
one has almost like rogue elements to it
where you have a city map and you're
choosing which level you want to go to
someone might be more suburban one might
be like a train one might be more like a
skyscraper kind of setting and you're
not locked to the individual screens
like you were in the first one you can
go up down any direction
the aliens are way more mobile this time
you have a double jump you can dive
dodge roll you have iframes on those
moves so that you're actually like you
can weave in and out of the chaos and
that's probably the most exciting thing
about Alien Hominid still is the chaos
that's on screen by the way also loot
new for this game you got hats you got
guns with all sorts of special abilities
you've got passive abilities so a lot of
differences from the first game in this
sequel / reimagining clash whatever they
want to call it I just call it Alien
Hominid invasion
[Music]
hear me out
undertale meets persona in an indie RPG
that's she dreams elsewhere now if you
know me that's speaking my language
having played it you kind of get the
undertale vibes from the retro style
from the perspective of when you're in
the overworld and especially when you're
in the perspective of combat because it
has that earthbound style but it draws a
lot of inspiration from persona when it
comes to the combat because of hitting
weaknesses and having different party
members with different skills now those
are the gameplay elements that hook me
but I think this game is more important
because it's coming from an independent
developer who's collabing with other
people but it's essentially a solo
project for developer Davion Goodin I
see a lot of the passion that's brought
into his game because he's writing it
and a lot of the dialogue a lot of the
character interactions come from an
honest place and I think it has a
creative freedom to create characters
that are more reflective of himself and
the people that he knows and that's kind
of what's shining through so I'm really
looking forward to she dreams elsewhere
it's speaking my language it's inspired
by the games that I love and I can't
wait to see what it is when it finally
launches
[Music]
my favorite game that I saw at PAX East
was Magic legends it looks a lot like
Diablo it plays a lot like Diablo and if
you have seen the Diablo before play
detail before you might see an isometric
action RPG and think I've seen this
before I've played just before the deck
building aspects really had a whole new
wrinkle to it rather than cycling
through cooldowns are actually cycling
through a deck of 12 cards the build
they had here was pretty overpowered you
can kind of hit any button and you do
something cool but you could tell just
by the little taste that I played that
eventually are gonna get to know your
deck well enough just like a real deck
builder where you're gonna know what the
powers are you gonna know what the icons
are you can read the screen instantly
and know when you want to trigger
certain spells it gives it a really cool
look and feel they had shown two classes
before the mind mage and the geomancer
those were basically an aggro and a sort
of back off hit from a distance the cool
new thing that showed here was called
the beasts collar which is basically a
summoner any class can summon beasts but
the beasts collar can summon a lot of
them a lot of their cards are built
around summoning beasts so I was just
rolling deep with like three or four big
big creatures at my back and we were
just taking down monsters like nothing
I've never gotten into the magic lore
but this game might actually finally
convince me
my favorite game I saw is recompile
which is a self-described Metroid
inspired game with a Tron aesthetic you
play as a computer program who's in a
hostile mainframe like I said the whole
thing it looks exactly like Tron Legacy
which is just like aesthetically one of
my favorite things ever so already
pretty on board with that the Metroid
inspired elements come in sort of the
way your character progresses at the
start you're just gaining simple
platforming abilities you can jump you
can double jump but then you get a gun
and it becomes a third-person shooter
and then you get the ability to hack
which allows you to freeze time and
manipulate objects you can move boxes
around and stack them which you can use
to solve different puzzles and then you
can also hack enemies and you can like
make them fight for you and that's where
the game just starts like escalating in
terms of like how your character like
interacts with the world eventually
you're gaining the ability to do like
the Metro like screwattack where you can
like infinitely jump and infinitely -
you get a glide ability that just lets
you fly anywhere in the world so there's
a huge level of freedom and how like you
interact with the world where you just
start very basic and by the end you're
just you can you explore this world in
any way you want
[Music]
so those are the games we were looking
forward to most from PAX East 2020 and
for more from the show you can check out
all the gameplay we've captured on our
YouTube pages that you can want our
impressions of everything we've played
and go to GameSpot calm and check out
our PAX East gallery thanks for watching
[Music]